[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes de la tnt tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité
d'abord nous irons rencontrer des
membres de la communauté harkie pour
connaître leur ressenti au lendemain de
la demande de pardon d'emmanuel macron
le président de la république ils ont 11
ans et sont harcelés sur les réseaux
sociaux du seul fait d'être nés en 2010
un sujet pris très au sérieux par
parents et enseignants dont vous
entendrez les témoignages dans ce
journal ça vous dirait de dormir dans
une maison toute ronde et bien ce sera
bientôt possible
étonnante habitations vont être
transformés en hôtels on voulait fait
visiter en exclusivité dans ce journal
et puis on finira par à un très jeune
champion de ski nautique qui se prépare
aux championnats du monde les images
estivale histoire de prolonger un peu
l'été en ce début d'automne
après la demande de pardon du président
de la république emmanuel macron aux
harkis antoine miami et charles arrigoni
de via occitanie ont tendu leurs micros
sur place à des membres de la communauté
des réactions plutôt positives
vous allez voir en occitanie la france
se rapproche un peu plus de la
reconnaissance de sa responsabilité dans
la souffrance des harkis ce lundi
emmanuel macron a demandé pardon à la
communauté d'origine algérienne qui
s'est battu pour la france durant la
guerre entre les deux pays abdel et fils
de harkis
pour lui c'est un terme fort et puissant
j'ai entendu aussi qui parlait de ne pas
oublier pour ne pas oublier il faut
transmettre et pour transmettre on doit
être partie prenante on doit également
transmettre dans les livres d'histoire à
toute cette jeunesse à toutes ces
générations leur expliquer l'histoire de
ces soldats de la france qui ont versé
leur sang pour défendre justement ces
valeurs républicaines
emmanuel macron a également annoncé une
loi de reconnaissance et de réparation
aujourd'hui les associations
représentant les arts qui demandent une
revalorisation des pensions des anciens
combattants
voici plusieurs semaines que parents et
enseignants s'inquiètent de voir fleurir
sur les réseaux sociaux ce mystérieux
hashtag 2010 adrien bletterie et céline
r s'il y a de tl7 sont allés à la
rencontre de certains d'entre eux à
saint-etienne pour la télévision de la
loire
cette musique que vous venez d'entendre
a provoqué des vagues d'insultés et de
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux envers
les jeunes nés en 2010 deux élèves de 5e
et de 3e à saint-etienne et témoignent
au collège claude fauriel on ne prend
pas le harcèlement la légère les élèves
sont sensibilisés dès leur rentrée sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment
aujourd'hui après avoir reçu un courrier
de l'éducation nationale suite au
hashtag le collège et se mobilisent une
nouvelle fois il y à une
cellule de veille
d'attention de ces élèves là ils sont
vus par l'infirmière l'infirmière en ce
moment est en train de mener justement
ses missions auprès des élèves de 6e
pour pouvoir s'en tire en tout cas
nous dire que tel ou tel élève à telle
ou telle situation vis à vis des drames
malgré ces efforts beaucoup d'élèves se
terre dans le silence et leur quotidien
est loin d'être agréable
des comportements fortement condamnée
par le collège le principal rappelle que
les enfants ne doivent pas être livrés à
eux mêmes c'est la responsabilité des
parents à vantoux lorsqu en autorisant
un enfant avoir un compte sur un réseau
social d'abord il faut avoir 12 ans et
plus et que et que des parents sont
aussi responsables de ce que peuvent
écrire leurs enfants pour soutenir les
élèves nés en 2010 un stack bienvenue au
sixième a été lancée aujourd'hui sur
twitter des milliers d'internautes le
relais encore et puis dans ce journal
des images d'une ferme photovoltaïque
tournées par nos amis de la dépêche sur
place 19 hectares de panneaux solaires
qui viennent d'être inaugurés à toulouse
en lieu et place de ce qui était jadis
l'usiné azf un lieu hautement symbolique
comme l'expliquent le président de
toulouse métropole devant les caméras de
nos confrères de la dépêche donc
que hier on était là pour commémorer
les 20 ans des trn un très très grand
malheur qui avait semé la mort et puis
ici l'énergie renouvelable énergie
solaire symbole de vie
symbole aussi de transition énergétique
qui préservent les ressources de la
planète et nous avons ici la centrale
photovoltaïque la plus importante qui
existe dans une grande ville française
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et roxana
maracineanu la ministre déléguée chargée
des sports était à yvré l'évêque en
sarthe pour promouvoir le sport à
l'école ils ont d'ailleurs eu droit à un
accueil un peu musclée une visite
racontée par anthony python et marco
bianco pour lm tv sartre sur place
a eu cette idée folle un jour de casser
l'école
[Musique]
cette chanson c'est celle des syndicats
d'enseignants même s'ils sont tenus à
distance par les gendarmes ils sont là
pour passer leur message
vous voulez simplement faire entendre à
jean-michel bancaire que tout le monde
on n'est pas dupe de sa com et on
voulait lui remettre une très belle
médaille olympique du saccage de l'école
publique à quelques mètres de là le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer air est en visite dans
l'école condorcet à yvré l'évêque
avec lui la ministre des sports roxana
maracineanu au coeur de la visite une
séance de relaxation pour les deux
ministres avec une classe d'élèves mais
leur présence c'est surtout
l'opportunité de décerner à l'école le
label génération 2024 un label qui
récompense les établissements scolaires
actifs dans le domaine du sport alors
aujourd'hui dans cette école primaire
comme dans d'autres nous avons voulu
aussi souligné l'importance de
l'opération 30 minutes d'activité
physique par jour parce que c'est pour
nous un enjeu vital de santé pour tous
nos enfants nous savons qu'il faut pour
les enfants comme pour les adultes
d'ailleurs bien bouger tous les jours
avoir une activité physique une
opération aussi voulu en lien avec les
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
paris 2024 c'est un continuum
l'éducation aux sports et l'éducation
par le sport doit exister beaucoup plus
fortement dans notre société c'est ça
aussi qui amènera de nombreux champions
plus tard mais aussi
des françaises et des français en bonne
santé parce que le sport c'est ça aussi
c'est les émotions que le sport nous
procure quand le regard mais aussi quand
le pratiquer le dispositif a été lancé
dans toutes les écoles élémentaires
il est basé sur le volontariat
et puis dans ce journal nous reparlons
des éoliennes elles sont loin de plaire
à tout le monde dans la vallée du
l'hygiène notamment dans les hauts de
france jérôme bouron de wéo est allé
prendre la température à leur propos et
on peut dire que tout cela est un peu
chaud regardez
c'est chaque jour le même spectacle
alors que laura sort ses vaches en
pâture difficile pour elle d' ignorer la
dizaine d'éoliennes dressé à quelques
centaines de mètres de là matin avant
quand j'allais chasse et mes vaches
c'était tout calme aujourd'hui on a un
petit bruit permanent dans l'oreille on
entend parler qui a des problèmes dans
certains élevages leur nombre de plus en
plus conséquent dans le secteur nous
font craindre qu'un jour mon troupeau et
des problèmes de santé quoi la vallée du
liger dans la somme compte déjà 18
éoliennes bientôt de nouveau parc
pourrait voir le jour avec 12 may
d'environ 130 mètres de haut depuis 2010
est l'association hazen freine ville
mène la révolte c'est une révolte à
villers mais aussi dans tout le vimeu
parce que ici on est submergé
d'éoliennes on en a partout on en a 400
dans un rayon de 20 km l'église gothique
flamboyant côtoie déjà le charme moderne
des éoliennes au delà des nuisances
visuelles ou auditives qu'elle dénonce
pour colette bourgois c'est tout le
patrimoine de la vallée du liger qui est
en jeu on a des très très jolie maison
et même les constructions plus récentes
elles sont remarquables l'église est
déjà sérieusement impacté par le blog
des 18 sur la ruelle pour continuer à en
être parce que le choc cédait qu'on va
voir vraiment un barrage dominique est
bénévole au conservatoire des espaces
naturels des hôtes france habitué des
sorties nature le retraité connaît la
richesse du monde argüelles située sur
une zone natura 2000 selon lui
l'implantation d'éoliennes aurait un
impact sur les populations de certaines
chauves souris les effectifs depuis 2018
ont fondu mais de façon incroyable j'en
étais à plus de 200
2018 maintenant on est à peine à 130 or
2020 selon la zenn freine ville les deux
projets éoliens nommé rossignol et haute
couture sont entrés en phase de
recevabilité 12 may qui s'ajouteront aux
2500 que conques les hauts de france
dont 960 dans la somme
des chiffres qui font encore mal en
france les maladies cardiovasculaires
sont à l'origine de 50000 mort subite
par an bénédicte dohin de teracent est
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest nous
emmène maintenant dans ce journal
découvrir l'institut de rythmologie et
de modélisation cardiaque de bordeaux un
centre à la pointe de la technologie qui
cherchent à mieux comprendre et à
traiter les dysfonctions électrique du
coeur un véritable espoir pour les
malades regardez ce sujet à deux pas de
l'hôpital haut lévêque lyrique est un
institut unique au monde entièrement
dédié aux maladies cardiaques ils
forment chaque année plus de 250
professionnels et étudiants grâce à une
technologie de pointe dans un premier
temps c'est d'apprendre les gestes c'est
à dire apprendre à manipuler des
cathéters à comprendre la relation qui
existe entre les images qui peuvent
avoir donc les images qu'ils ont fait
d'opérations les signaux qui vont
observer sur les cathéters et la
pathologie du patient donc là en fait on
dispose de coeur imprimé en 3 2 en 3 d
ici qui ont qui sont qui ont une texture
relativement souple qui fait penser aux
textures de réelles baker donc ça permet
d'avoir une sensation qui est très
proche de celle qu'on aura sur un passe
temps réel les équipes de l'iric
participe actuellement un projet
européen de recherche à travers cette
étude une révolution thérapeutique est
en marche 11 millions de patients
pourraient être sauvées en europe cette
étude bitèye f c'est pour nous
l'occasion de démontrer de manière
scientifique et irréfutable que cette
nouvelle énergie l'électroporation
permet de faire des interventions qui
sont plus rapide plus simple plus
efficace et plus sûr que la technique
actuellement utilisées en routine qui
s'appelle la radiofréquence et qui
consiste à brûler le tissu pour aller
toujours plus loin dans ses recherches
l'institut lance une campagne de levée
de fonds objectif atteindre les 10
millions d'euros d'ici 2024 autre chose
dans l'actualité et dans ce journal
besoin de chercher un emploi il vient à
vous ou presque le bus de la cité des
métiers parcours les côtes d'armor pour
aller à la rencontre des personnes en
quête de nouvelles orientations un sujet
de mathilde de kenner de tébéo la chaîne
du groupe le télégramme sur place
j'aime arriver dans la région d'accord
donc voilà j'ai enfin chercheurs
d'emploi mais en même temps j'ai assez
de voir pour nous désormais en côtes
d'armor un drôle de camions traversent
les campagnes il s'agit du bus des
métiers à son bord deux salariés de la
cité des métiers loin de leur bureau à
ploufragan elle se déplace désormais
pour aider les personnes à faire leur cv
trouver une formation ou tout simplement
trouvé sa voie à l'image de cette jeune
femme après une heure d'entretien elle
ressort avec différents outils mais très
instructif du bien de se sentir un petit
peu en compagnie c'est pas évident quand
on cherche un point pour les territoires
qui sont peut-être un peu plus excentré
c'est pas toujours facile d'accès on
peut par exemple qu'on apprend n'a pas
le permis ou qu'on n'a pas les
transports en commun donc ça nous permet
de rendre service et d'informer tous les
publics partout ces entretiens sont
gratuits et sans rendez vous un concept
innovant lancé par une structure unique
dans la région la cité des métiers cd
volonté politique des volontés locales
d'installer des cités des métiers sur le
territoire les côtes d'armor
ont été précurseurs c'est quasiment
enfin c'est une des premières cités des
métiers qui a ouvert en france dans les
côtes d'armor lancé en mai le bus a
accueilli à ce jour 340 personnes et
sillonne les côtes d'armor trois jours
par semaine les dates sont à retrouver
sur le site internet de la cité des
métiers
et puis dans ce journal maintenant je
vous propose de vous embarquer à bord de
bateaux très spéciaux ceux d'une
association créée par des caribéens en
2020 dans le but d'améliorer la
conservation des cétacés à travers toute
la grande région caraïbe et même au delà
un reportage en haute mer signée tom
gagnon pour vyas atv martinique sur
place
deuxième jour d'expédition pour la ccs a
pris une heure de navigation
la chance sourit enfin au loin les
chercheurs aperçoivent plusieurs
ailerons à la surface donc là on a des
globicéphales tropicaux qu'on peut voir
on a un groupe qui est environ entre 10
et 20 individus on voit qu'ils sont en
train de ceux qui seront à peine en
resting ceux qui sont posées
[Musique]
les cétacés se dirige vers le sud
un instant magique auquel l'équipage ne
peut rester insensible
c'est toujours aussi excitant surtout
que l'hydro phone a bien parlé ce matin
et du coup on était vraiment frustré de
pas les voir de les entendre donc du
coup c'est vraiment une bénédiction et
un joli cadeau de la nature
depuis sa création la ccs a pu observer
des dizaines d'espèces de cétacés
différentes au gré de ses expéditions
l'association récolte des données
précieuses sur le comportement de ces
mammifères et pour la première fois en
martinique les chercheurs ont capté des
enregistrements sonores d'orques les
antilles s'avère être une zone
particulièrement intéressante si on
regarde la totalité des espèces ils sont
connus dans le monde c'est-à-dire 91
actuellement il y en a trente trois qui
ont déjà été observés ici donc ça reste
une zone qui est très riche puisque on a
quand même un tiers de la biodiversité
mondiale qui est présente dans nos zones
dit qu'on va faire un petit point sur ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui pour donner plus
d'écho à sa mission jeffrey a souhaité
impliquer les acteurs locaux des
scientifiques de la sara et de la cepa
marques participent expédition ils sont
formés sur le terrain c'est une démarche
stratégique centrale pour pouvoir
sensibiliser le public en particulier
les résidents de toutes les îles montrer
effectivement ce qu'il y a comme
richesse dans les eaux territoriales de
ça à ce que le public s'approprie
le sujet de la biodiversité qui subit
une érosion très marquée ces dernières
années dès lundi jeffrey reprendra son
périple vers la guadeloupe là bas il
espère croiser d'autres espèces et
récolter de nouvelles données
croissant vert dans ce journal cette
fois ci il s'agit de la méditerranée et
plus précisément à monaco où le yachting
se veut plus écoresponsable monaco info
nos confrères sur place met en lumière
un programme soutenu par la fondation du
prince albert qui promeut des outils
pour aider les plaisanciers à réduire
leurs dépenses énergétiques et à mieux
traiter les eaux et les déchets la voie
royale pour devenir plus vert regardez
ce sujet
le smart yachting est aujourd'hui un axe
d'avenir pour la principauté c'est une
composante plein de potentiel pour la
transformation de l'économie et de
l'attractivité monégasque les outils
numériques occupe une place de plus en
plus stratégique les plaisanciers
veulent avoir du réseau veulent avoir
des supports électrique veulent avoir la
sécurité et le but dans un monde qui
change est de faire du marketing donc
ils croissance pour l'entreprise
actuelle un train de nouvelles
entreprises nous entrepreneurs de venir
en principauté pour développer ces
technologies pour développer ses outils
pour doper ses solutions au service de
l'école monégasque ce programme est
soutenu par la fondation prince albert
ii les nouvelles technologies dont le
digital permettent de mettre en oeuvre
la transition énergétique par l'adoption
des énergies renouvelables et la
protection des océans la principauté
entend ainsi renforcer son statut de
capitale mondiale du yachting dans un
esprit plus responsable c'est à la fois
la propulsion comment réduire
les dépenses énergétiques
quelles sont les alternatives
au pétrole on suit attentivement les
développements en termes d'hydrogène
mais aussi de panneaux solaires ensuite
le traitement des eaux le traitement des
déchets à bord de ces navires pour
réduire au maximum l'impact de la haute
plaisance sur les écosystèmes marins tel
un laboratoire d'innovation la
principauté a le pouvoir de tester ses
solutions cette année par exemple monaco
yacht show couvrira une activité
éco-responsable et intégrera le
développement des marinas dans un
écosystème durable
et nous repartons maintenant nouvelle
aquitaine à limoges plus précisément où
a eu lieu un mariage quelque peu
insolite celui de la porcelaine de
limoges et du street art deux univers
qui n'étaient pas destinés à se
rencontrer et cela aurait vraiment été
dommage vous allez le voir une union à
laquelle a assisté à l'un druot pour cet
animal nos confrères sur place
comme un éléphant le graffeur n'est a
priori pas à sa place dans un magasin de
porcelaine j'espère que ça va rendre
bien ces petites grenouilles ces petits
champignons et mon collègue qui fait un
grand chaman à côté je pense que ça peut
être sympa le porcelainier grégory
rosenblatt aurait pu peindre les murs de
sa nouvelle manufacture en blanc mais il
est amateur de street art et ça change
tout nous on en rêve en bleu de faux en
fait une couleur savoir faire c'est
c'est une partie de l'histoire de
l'entreprise que le projet jalonnement
notamment quand il s'agit de mettre en
valeur un savoir faire
ea du design guily à de larbi a quelque
chose de contemporain en fait c'est
assez naturel 30 graffeurs venus des six
coins du pays ont travaillé tout un
week-end c'est extrêmement rare on avait
déjà vu cette opportunité à bordeaux
avec un fabricant de papier temps je
pensais que ça m'arriverait qu'une fois
dans ma vie mais
l'histoire se répète et le mur
totalement vierge il va devenir ça il va
devenir ça alors avec des graphes
disséminées un peu aux endroits
stratégiques de la composition avec
différentes déjà matière on va garder un
petit peu de sa sueur sur notre
composition finale et puis au centre
donc une composition figurative un petit
peu de style science fiction
voilà un univers qui nous parle bien et
dans un peu plus d'un mois le site
prendra vie avec le déménagement de la
chaîne de production
et puis un chiffre qui va vous
intéresser dans ce journal maintenant en
france seulement 2,1 pour cent des 27
millions d'actifs utilisé un vélo pour
aller travailler un mode de transport
plus écolo certes qui tend à se
démocratiser dans les grandes villes
notamment céline charles de tv 78 dans
les yvelines est allé à la rencontre de
vélo tu as peur qu'on les appelle
heureux regarder ça
il est 8h et au lieu de monter dans sa
voiture comme la plupart des français
christian enfourche son vélo tous les
matins il dépose sa fille à l'école et
se rend au travail en vélo une pratique
qui ne changerait pour rien au monde ça
fait un an que je suis sur ce poste ça
fait un an que je viens toujours à vélo
alors que j'ai un scooter un bus direct
voiture et mais franchement une fois
qu'on a pris le couvent les il faut s'y
mettre on traverse étaient comme des
beaux endroits on a quand même une
région qui est assez entre bois d'arcy
et ici c'est quand même assez rebours et
il ya pas mal de pistes cyclables c'est
tranquille s'est détendu embouteillages
pollution carburant ou encore
stationnement de plus en plus de
personnes délaissent les moyens de
transport habituel pour se mettre au
vélo les avantages sont nombreux on fait
un peu d'exercice c'est pas mal on
s'aère un peu l'esprit et le corps pas
de bas de page navigo pour le transport
pas de parking pas de klaxons pas de
bouchon à l'arrivée christian dépose son
vélo dans la ville aux stations de saint
quentin en yvelines créé il ya quatre
ans par l'agglomération elle offre pour
30 euros par an des multiples services à
ceux qui comme christian ont fait le
choix de se déplacer à vélo tous les
jours le premier service dont passer la
consigne dont monsieur bénéficie pour
pouvoir garer son vélo en toute sécurité
le deuxième service ça va être donc la
location de vélos trois types de vélos
vélos standard vélos à assistance
électrique vélo clients et troisième
pied donc de la vélostation de l'atelier
de réparation alors vélo transports en
commun ou voiture il n'ya plus à hésiter
pour ceux qui seraient convaincus la
vélostation propos jusqu'au 22 septembre
encore un vélo à 40 euros pour un an je
vous le disais dans les titres de ce
journal de drôles de vaisseau
extraterrestre se sont posés dans les
vosges en réalité il s'agit de maisons
bull classé aux monuments historiques et
bientôt transformé en hôtel en attendant
de pouvoir y dormir aurait lié
colombelles et hélène le plat de votre
télévision nous ont fait le tour du
propriétaire
regardez ce reportage
installé sur cette île formé par la
rivière de la plaine à raon l'étape ce
petit village intrigue les journées du
patrimoine est l occasion de s'approcher
des maisons bulle de l'architecte pascal
as other man ça fait mal au coeur de
voir que de les voir partir comme ça en
se délabrer finalement classé aux
monuments historiques depuis 2014 ces
constructions ont vécu de multiples
péripéties en 1967 ses chambres ont été
construites pour servir d'extension à un
hôtel el inspireront dans les années
soixante dix les créateurs de la famille
barbapapa les bungalows passe dans les
mains de plusieurs propriétaires je les
ai connu
sa période qui était complètement envahi
par la végétation on voyait vraiment
plus grand chose du lieu vous savez un
petit goût d'interdît parce que bah
c'est une île donc on ne peut pas
franchir sans passer par la rivière etc
donc quand on est gamin et quand on voit
ça ça toujours pas le côté barbapapa
enfin qui rappellent tous des souvenirs
d'enfance en 2006 les bulles retrouvent
leur vocation d'origine les
propriétaires ouvrent le musée au motel
avec un style des années 50-70 toute
blanche
au moment de pâques elle était
emmailloté de ruban est haute pour faire
les oeufs et puis il y avait la chasse
aux oeufs pour les enfants qui se
passait dans le secteur c'était assez
génial mais la structure hôtelière
peinent à être rentables ferme en 2016
et finit par être vendus aux enchères un
parisien en fait l'acquisition le
nouveau propriétaire la volonté de
rouvrir ce lieu au public comme au motel
donc ça c'est une très très bonne
nouvelle les accords de travaux sont
tombés donc on va pouvoir attaquer les
travaux en 2022 pour une ouverture pour
l'été 2023 le motel bas other man
retrouvera aussi son nom d'origine l'eau
vive avec à la clé un nouveau décor
intérieur pour ces logements insolites
voilà nous ouvrons une page de sport
dans ce journal ce n'est ni du hand ball
ni du volley-ball ni même de la pelote
basque c'est sans doute un peu les trois
à la fois le tchoukball c'est le nom de
ce sport inventé par un médecin suisse
avec l'idée de créer un sport sans
contact pour éviter les blessures et si
le coeur vous en dit de vous y mettre
voici un petit lexique des règles
expliqué au micro de 8,9 l'an regarde
y'a pas de quand on joue des deux côtés
de chaque côté il ya ce qu'on appelle un
cadre qui ressemble à un trampoline le
tour de ce qu'a dit à une zone qui fait
trois mètres et le but du jeu en fait
c'est stratégiquement de faire circuler
la balle sur le terrain pour arriver à
tirer sur mieux de ce cadre et que la
balle ressortent de cette zone de 3
mètres pour marquer un point la
particularité c'est que c'est un sport
sans contact donc il n'ya pas
d'interception de jeu en fait on a la
balle que quand l'équipe adverse a tiré
ou a fait une faute et le but du jeu
c'est de se faire des passes on a
jusqu'à trois passes pour faire circuler
la balle à bâle et créer des
opportunités dans la défense pour
pouvoir marquer un point vous l'avez vu
dans les titres sport toujours dans ce
journal mais cette fois ci sur l'eau
avec des images de notre consoeur et
lise denis pour tlc ce tout jeune
champion de ski nautique n'a que 14 ans
pierre louis germain originaire de
cholet a été médaillé de bronze aux
championnats d'europe cet été et il
prépare les sélections des championnats
du monde qui auront lieu l'année
prochaine on lui souhaite donc bonne
chance pour la suite qui s'annonce des
plus prometteuses pour ce jeune champion
j'ai commencé à 8 ans et demi le ski
nautique en vacances en corse j'ai bien
aimé donc j'ai voulu en faire on a
découvert le club de cholet et donc
ensuite je suis venu ici après j'ai bien
aimé donc j'ai continué j'ai commencé
avec eux un tour environ toutes les
semaines après ça devenait tous les
jours et ensuite après on partait à
bordeaux le week-end
voilà et pour cette fin de journal on se
quitte sur des images assez étonnante
celle d'une marionnette qui il faut bien
le dire est loin de passer inaperçue et
pour cause elle mesure 3 mètres
cinquante de haut à mal c'est son nom
elle représente une enfant syrienne qui
fait un périple de huit mille kilomètres
à travers l'europe pour sensibiliser sur
le sort des migrants j'étais là parce
qu'après son passage par marseille avec
des images que vous voyez sur cet écran
réalisé par william pitt johnny de la
provence eh bien elle doit se rendre à
briançon à lyon à strasbourg à
charleville mézières et à paris voilà
c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes tnt et sur tv5 monde on
se retrouve pour une prochaine édition
on pourra tous au revoir
[Musique]
ouais